- Und wir fahren jetzt zu der
Frau mit der Wunde?
- Genau, die mit der infizierten Wunde,
die versorgen wir heute noch.
Genau, wichtig ist, das Bein
zwischendurch immer hochzulegen,
gerade wenn Sie irgendwie
Fernsehen gucken oder so
oder mal ein Mittagsschläfchen machen.
Genau, damit die Lymphflüssigkeit
einfach ein bisschen abfließen kann.
Fördert auch immer die Wundheilung.
Wir haben jetzt einmal die
Wundauflage draufgetan.
Vorher haben wir das schön desinfiziert,
damit wir die Bakterien und Keime einmal
reduzieren und auch abtöten können.
Die Wunde sieht ja insgesamt
deutlich besser aus.
- Geht auch schon besser.
- Genau, die Infektion ist noch sichtbar.
Wie ist das denn mit
den Schmerzen aktuell?
- Na ja, könnte besser gehen.
- Okay.
Wichtig ist immer, dass man das
Wundexsudat aufnehmen kann,
dass das einfach nicht durchsezerniert.
Das ist immer wichtig,
dass du das beachten musst.
Und auch ruhig dann auch die Patientin
fragen, ob das zu fest ist oder nicht,
weil jetzt haben wir die Möglichkeit,
dann auch noch was zu tun.
Geht das so?
- Alles super.
- Ja? Wunderbar.
Das Bein wieder ablegen.
Genau, und einmal gut festhalten, ne?
Wichtig ist dann auch wirklich, die
Mullbinde nochmal zu fixieren,
da haben wir das Fixomull für.
- Das rutscht nicht.
- Haftet auch ganz gut, genau,
weil gerade am Unterschenkel –
da die Patientin sich ja auch noch viel
bewegen möchte oder wird,
dass das nicht runterrutscht.
Und dann kannst du
hier noch mal kontrollieren:
Wenn da so ein Finger reinpasst,
dass es auch nicht zu eng ist.
Du kannst ruhig mal probieren.
Genau.
Ansonsten Verband drauflassen, nicht
drangehen und auch nicht nass machen.
- Prima. Kein Problem.
- Super, alles klar, dann war’s das.
- Super.